this is the craziest story that hit the
news
yesterday and I I didn't really comment
on it directly yesterday because it was
so shocking I I didn't I felt it was
even distasteful to talk about it now
enough time has gone by I everyone's
already talking about it this guy Josh
Krueger is a liberal
activist and Josh
Krueger three days ago made fun of Scott
Adams the Dilbert comic and somewhat
vaguely conservative commentator who's a
very interesting guy and has you know
obviously had a very successful
career Scott Adams three years ago
tweeted out if Biden is elected there's
a good chance you will be dead within
the year that was July 2020 three days
ago Josh
Krueger tweets out the Dilbert dude is
like no stradamus look at this
prediction from 2020 wow Eerie so he's
making fun of him he's saying yeah we're
all supposed to be dead and you know
we're not dead what an idiot this guy is
and then two days after that Josh
Krueger was murdered in his Philadelphia
home and now the Dilbert guy is being
called
Nostradamus this is really weird we got
it's New York Times is reporting on this
Philadelphia journalist is killed in his
home Josh Krueger 39 was shot seven
times the police said that no arrests
had been made we don't know if the if
the people who killed him knew him or if
it was just another home Breakin like
there's so many of them in Philadelphia
so now people are saying wow Scott Adams
is predicting the future and it's weird
the timing is a little bit Eerie
obviously not for the reasons that Mr
Krueger
thinks I don't think that we should be
uh happy about this obviously I know
some people think they have a little
shot in fory to here because the guy who
downplayed all of the risks of living in
these kinds of cities and downplayed the
spike crime he ended up having to deal
with the consequences of that obviously
we should just pray for this guy's soul
and pray for ourselves too uh but what
do we make of Scott Adams does he
predict the
future no he only sort of Scott Adams
only sort of predicts the
future in the same way that prophets
predict the future people misunderstand
what a prophet is a priest friend of
mine uh father rutler has an excellent
line on this he says prophets do not
primarily predict the future but rather
see the
present they they predict the future
only in a derivative
sense in as much as telling the truth
will tell you something about how the
future is going to
unfold the number of murders in
Philadelphia has more than doubled over
the last decade it does not take a
Nostradamus to know that people are more
likely to be murdered in these cities so
some people deny that reality other
people just tell the
truth they just see the present they
tell the truth as they see it and when
when you tell the truth in an age that
is defined by
lies you're going to look like you're
predicting the future but you're not
you're just being honest with yourself
and making an observation and and also
having the Integrity to tell tell other
people that observation to too now one
place where you're going to definitely
want integrity and honesty is when
you're hiring people which is why you
got to check out zip recruiter right now
go to ziprecruiter.com I would like to
give a hand to all those whose job it is
to hire from the small business owners
growing their team to the HR directors
hiring hundreds Across the Nation you
have one of the toughest jobs there is
hiring a good HR team is one of the most
important things you can do with zip
recruiter you can make your whole hiring
process faster and easier zip
recruiter's powerful technology works
for for you to identify people whose
skills and experience match your job zip
recruiter saves you Time by letting you
easily invite your top candidates to
apply to your job so they're more likely
to apply sooner zip recruiter is trusted
by over 3.8 million businesses for their
hiring needs Hiring Heroes let Z
recruiter help make your job easier four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day go to zip recruiter.com
kwes to try zi recruiter for free that
is ziprecruiter.com
o wle s these guys are the best in the
business they make they are best in
business I guess because they make it so
easy for your business to hire
ziprecruiter.com
klees right now go to EK
pure.com most people only think about
poor air quality when we have fires like
the ones that were just happening in
Canada America's evil Top Hat causing
New York to be a strange orange color
that made the air quality absolutely
terrible have you stopped to think about
the polluted air in your day-to-day life
you and your family's health might be
affected by the air quality in your home
allergens and germs floating in the air
that you breathe can make you sick but
the good news is that there is
technology out there that helps you
purify your living space easily and
affordably with
envirocleanse you will never have to
worry again envirocleanse is an inhome
air purifying unit designed to destroy
cold and flu viruses allergy inflaming
toxins mold and even more viral cleanse
promises far fewer colds allergies and
better sleep their air purifiers come in
all sizes colors and prices to fit every
budget and they offer additional
products like Surface Cleaner and
laundry detergent breathe in pure air
and live a healthier life visit EK
pure.com use code NES KW for 10% off
your enviral cleanse home air
purification unit right now you will
also get their free air quality monitor
plus fast free shipping that is $150 in
savings EK pure.com code NS EK pure.com
promo code nolles Costco has a new
product that they are selling out of and
that is gold
bars I love this story I can't believe
this exists Costco has everything man
they've got 150 hot dogs with unlimited
refills of Diet Coke and nice little
ground up onions on it they've got free
samples you can make a brunch out of it
they've got massage chairs they've got
chinos and Oxford shirts they've got
50,000 packs of czer they've got
everything and now they have bars of
gold that they are sell selling out of
part of the reason they're selling out
is because you know this if you're a
Costco ficient auto as I am if you get
the slightly more expensive Costco card
then you get 2% back and apparently you
get 2% back on gold as well so you're
you're getting an effective 2% discount
on uh every ounce of gold you buy which
is pretty great but also what this tells
us is people don't have confidence in
the stock market this is an actual
political indicator the fact that Costco
can't stock gold bars fast enough
is an indicator that people don't
believe the stock market they think it's
headed for a crash I think it's probably
headed for a crash or at least a
significant dip that's going to affect
the 2024 race as well we we are still
grappling with the insane inflation that
came to us by way of coid lockdowns and
Joe Biden's massive spending and at the
time the whole time we were told that
inflation was not going to be an issue
it that actually they were going to curb
inflation that Joe Biden was going to
pass the inflation reduction Act that
was going to curb inflation though it
didn't and all serious analyses on it
suggest that it either didn't affect
inflation or made inflation worse what
has thus far controlled inflation in to
the degree that it has been controlled
is the fed the FED finally raising
interest rates
but our economy is extremely precarious
right now and you can have all the
Geniuses on TV and their suits and ties
saying oh no everything's great Joe
Biden's doing fine it's the most
wonderful economy ever
uh when people stop stocking up on the
gold bars then I'll finally believe that
boy what a great clip that was now make
sure that you ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael NS YouTube channel see
you next time